au lac et a lancé me gausse d'internet
écouter aujourd'hui on retombe sur ce
nouveau disque on avait déjà fait à
l'époque tant ils étaient exterminés et
ses liens c'était le wat coude govou en
français comment ça pourrait mal se
passer
il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup de nouveaux
postes de planar fois c'est très très
drôle ce concept prend là là ça c'est
quelqu'un qui fait découvrir la vert à
sa mère si vous n'aimez pas votre mère
faites lui découvrir la mer au nom du
film et le jeu de la poutre que le
pourrait-il mal se passer au l'enfant
j'ai peur pour enfants j'ai très peu
plus
mais qu'est ce qu'il a fait très haut
elle était heureuse là de se jeter il
c'est quoi ce réflexe et l'incroyable ce
jeu les faits à l'époque extrême en
automne et en hiver quand tu joues à ce
jeu tu as envie de tout sauf de tomber
de la poutre ll s'est jeté de la poudre
les gars excusez moi mais là on est en
train de mettre le doigt sur quelque
chose d'un peu plus profond elle a vu là
l'occasion de mettre fin à ses jours
peut-être n'y a pas de j'ai laissé mon
chat snif et où le pot de 4 craque alors
le cas de krach c'est de l'herbe à chat
évidemment ce grand mystère de
l'humanité au delà des pyramides
pourquoi la vie tout ça pourquoi l'herbe
à chat stimule autant nos chats ya des
chats qui réagissent pas du tout voir ça
les stresse et d'autre ils sont
complètement accro à l'herbe à chat mais
vraiment l'odeur les stimule énormément
et il se met 3 yards c'est devenu un
kraken frérot wah wah j'ai peur des
chats qui d'autre en grandissant se met
à avoir un peu peur déjà vite fait pas
jumbo jet me fait pas peur mais des
chats que tu connais pas et tout s'est
un peu de méfiance que pourrait-il mal
se passer si j'essaie d'entrer par
effraction dans cette maison quoi mes
mecs serait d'horreur alerte aux traders
en change de décor ce le mac elle est
horrible cette situation t as laitages
et tu vois un mec essayer de rentrer
mais c'est horrible
mehdi lui quelque chose
pasqua je suis qui va voir le gall film
et va partir en courant les flics vont
arriver excuse moi mais le cri c'est moi
quand je mets un cache cache et qu'on me
trouve j'ai la même réaction
cardo je comprends pourquoi le gaver
rien dit à la fenêtre il a juste appeler
la police puis s'est pas mis en danger
il a attendu tranquille excuse moi mais
c'est la première vidéo convoi tiré d'un
trait noir
c'est incroyable que pourrait-il arriver
de pas cool mes frères mes soeurs
je vous invite à tous mettre votre main
de la sorte sur la tempe et le point sur
le coeur
c'est un sas aguets chao pour cet
individu elle va y arriver je suis en
train de douter
oh non pour le premier sa saga où là
aussi aller sur le cerveau dit c'est que
[Musique]
pourrait-il arriver de mal quand tu
essaies de voler la voiture de quelqu'un
qui est en train de faire un plein
d'essence
oh là là le pam à hantise les plains
c'est un moment où je suis terrifiée
quand je suis en panne d'essence
oh là là au plein sens et ce entre
essence asperges ados way s'est pas
dégonflé au lieu des gars je réalise
j'aurais même pas fait ça moi la
camionnette
elle se gare même si c'est un gars qui
me ramène un truc que j'ai perdu sur la
route je pars en cours que pourrait-il
arriver de mal en essayant de courir
dans une grande roue pour hamster on en
arrive arrive il va aller vite et à
privas pas assuré la vitesse et il va
décoller oh non non non
comment tweak sorti les baisers c'est
très dur de inox tac a pris cher
puisqu'il a voulu tenter la exactement
le gard un trauma crânien mais il le
prend bien quand même
mais ça c'est la caméra ça garder le
sourire quoi qu'il arrive alors que tu
es au plus bas dans ta tête
que pourrait-il arriver de mal quand tu
ne regardes pas en direction de l'as où
tu marches
or les gars j'ai des flashs back de mon
père quand j'étais petit j'adorais
avancé et pas regarder devant moi donc
père il me restait les gars c'était
incroyable il faisait cette phrase
regarde devant toi et un jour c'est ce
qui s'est passé je me suis pété les
dogues ce que j'ai pas regardé devant
moi je crois que je pourrais je me suis
pris une barrière en fer c'est bon ciao
lui il court très très vite ça se voit
elle elle va se prendre 18 g dans le
hall a dit juger c'est terminé retour au
point de départ
direction la réincarnation ciao bon
allez bata céladon sibelga ils vont
juste les boîtes de la ps5
il ya quarante quatre gars qui sont en
train d'en chérir dessus ça c'est un
nouveau type d'arnaqué n'y a sur les
enchères il ya des gars aussi là avec la
mode des dix plaies pokémon il vante
juste une des photos du display est en
fait si tu lis vite fait titre c'est
tellement bien formulé tu te rends pas
compte que ce que tu achètes c'est juste
une photo d'un display première
génération et il ya des enchères elle
monta genre des milliers d'euros c'est
u2 photo à l'arrivée j'ai presque envie
d'essayer
n'en faites pas ça c'est pas bien
regardé ce que je disais à quelques
minutes la preuve qu'il faut toujours se
méfier de ces modifs est là
[Musique]
ah ah ah
les gars j'ai la phobie de ça en fait ça
m'est arrivé jean une fois et demi et je
les très très mal vécu je n'ai confiance
quand je me moque ce soit bien clair
tous vos chats là quand j'arrive chez
vous qui viennent gratter des câlins je
sais ce qu'ils veulent ils veulent me
soulever [ __ ] mais telle est loin de
moi je ne suis pas à l'aise avec eux
sauf le dispense les exotiques sur terre
et bleue est un peu les ragdolls bon ok
je t'ai vu la vérité je pense qu'il
s'est coincé une griffe et du coup le
chat il est parti en panique
et comme le mec à dix fois plus paniqué
que le chat le chat s'est mis à 20 fois
plus paniqué que le mec et ça a donné
une courbe exponentielle de la panique
qui s'affiche actuellement sous vos yeux
vraie question que pourrait-il mal se
passer quand tu es un énorme stickers de
traces deux cents au dessus des roues
dégâts sur une échelle du mauvais goût
on est à combien n'ont réellement après
peut-être c'est halloween
ça n'excuse rien ont ils ont mis un
toboggan dans les bureaux lorraine faut
qu'on fasse ça c'est extraordinaire
il a voulu faire bien il a voulu
s'intégrer utiliser le toboggan de
l'entreprise
il revenait du bureau du boss pour lui
demander une promotion et grâce à cette
gaffe il l'a obtenu calculé ça c'est un
cambriolage lui évidemment c'est le
cambrioleur et tombe sur le propriétaire
qui regardez moi bien cette paire de
couilles si le fusil à pompe directement
le mec est plus léger que moi il emmène
au sol le ravisseur mais là il se mettra
le cambrioleur avait choqué il le blesse
même pas il dit juste frais rouge et un
fusil à pompe pourquoi t'as fait ça
laisse moi juste volé et c'est bon la
chance de rendement sera pourquoi tu
fais le héros là par les bulls du mec
mais je vais dire ce serait pas arrivé
s'il avait regardé ma vidéo sur la self
défense
[Musique]
je n'ai pas le temps de plonger dedans
j'ai rien compris pourquoi il a accroché
son caleçon à une corde c'est très
mauvaise équipe et pourquoi il ya autant
de points de vue différents
cette hausse est pourquoi il ya un
couple avec deux enfants qui passent
qu'est ce que c'est que ça qu'est-ce qui
peut mal se passer
je reconnais ce gars est le regard d'un
rival on dirait pas du tout qu'il est
désolé on dirait qu'ils insultent la
dans sa tête comme un resto à tous ces
sales d'afrique rodez pour avoir les
pieds sur le tableau de bord lors d'un
accident de voiture
plus personne ne fera jamais ça parmi
tous ceux qui ont regardé cette vidéo on
vient d'assister à la meilleure campagne
de sensibilisation du monde
que pourrait-il arriver quand tu fais ta
demande en mariage sur le très fréquenté
pont de brooklyn au nom qu'est ce qui va
gâcher
[Applaudissements]
ah ça tue ils ont le meilleur souvenir
de la demande or c'est tellement mieux
que les trucs n'y en eut en eau les
parcs aquatiques
ça manque d'avoir des verrues au pied
quand j'en reviens huawei est ce qui
s'est passé ça c'est sympa en plus
j'aime beaucoup mais la dangerosité non
les gars le staff s'il vous plaît faites
un effort
là on est où on actionne par classe et
comment en 2021 merde
que peut-il arriver de mal quand
j'essaie n'en firent lors de mon procès
au la chute
vous pensez le fait qu'il essaie de le
rattraper au juste de l'arrêter en plein
air j'ai un vrai doute chez un vrai vrai
doute écrit
inop's taille mais qu'est ce que tu fais
0% pour les obstacles dont toutes les
vidéos qu'est ce qui m'arrive que
pourrait-il mal se passer en baladant la
princesse en bas des marches
oh non mais ouah c'est prémédité
je vois pas d'autre solution c'est une
tentative de renversement du pouvoir en
place c'est pas possible autrement
que peut-il arriver quand on met un
câble électrique derrière des grappes de
raisin excusez moi mais c'est pas
courant
oh j'ai fait un jeu de mots là je suis
pas peu fier donc c'est une exposé sur
les différentes grappes de raisin
attendez attendez c'est un coup du kgb
non mais c'est quoi la probable mettre
ta main dans des grappes et de tirer un
câble électrique ya un gars du cachet
bda le raisin je suis sûr si on zoome on
le voit jouer des coudes ouais
et bien mes amis c'est la fin de ce
merveilleux sevrés dit que j'affectionne
tant j'espère qu'il vous a plu vous a
passé un très bon moment en lega je me
rends compte que j'étais vachement bas
j'aurais dû être comme ça normalement
j'étais comme ça toute la vie dlc pack
subtil ok je suis hyper grand à l'esa
s'inquiète charles est excusé
sow est une odyssée ouais si ma grotte
de bottines tél